Jonathan Cox is battalion chief for Cal
Fire's Northern California region he's
with us from Redding good morning chief
Cox how are you good morning Thank You
chief Cox you face another day of triple
digit temperatures there how much
progress is being made in in the fight
against the car fire yes the car fire
we're cautiously optimistic that the
progression into the city of Redding the
very highly populated area has slowed
and if not stopped and that's been just
our number one priority as all these
areas that are populated and have
structures to get the the fire to stop
there the issue we have now is as we
start the repopulation and recovery on
the one side the other side of the fire
is very active and additional
evacuations are going into place on top
of that we're also fighting the actual
direct fire itself so there's kind of
three main things going on at once right
now but obviously they're all important
really difficult chief you just heard
from Edie blood so he lost his wife and
his two great grandkids he said he
didn't receive an evacuation warning how
are you warning people to evacuate yeah
so the way it works is on these days we
have air attack in the sky who's looking
down and seeing the progression of this
fire I know on Thursday night when the
fire exploded into reading they were in
coordination with the commanders as well
as the the Sheriff's Office and police
departments to get warnings out ahead of
this far as much as possible what
conditions we saw on the Thursday night
here in Redding kind of what people are
calling a weather phenomenon or an
anomaly where a natural possible vortex
came through here and that's literally
fire behavior that we have not
experienced or seen or witnessed in a
generation here in Northern California
and unfortunately you know it just it
tears that firefighters hearts to
obviously have any loss of life or
injuries I've heard stories of
firefighters bringing family members out
and having the windows of their car
explode from the conditions that were
out there so the number one priority for
us is always getting people out as
quickly as possible and it always breaks
our heart when we can't get everybody
out chief
the New York Times reports this weekend
that since 2012 there has not
then a month without a wildfire burning
given the fact that you have 12,000
firefighters fighting nine fires do you
have the resources you need given the
unprecedented and unrelenting nature of
these fires yeah so you know we call
this the new normal in California and
we've seen larger and more destructive
fires a year over a year and
unfortunately this year doesn't look to
be any different and we see these surges
or these sieges coming through the state
we're have a hundred and fifty
additional engines coming in from other
states right now and we put them in
places where the priorities are and we
have the ability to draw from National
Guard as well so unfortunately this new
normal is kind of upon us in California
more deadly more destructive fires more
often and it's and it's obviously
requiring additional resources not just
from California but throughout the
United States too to get ahead of it
we know you're working hard we're
thinking of you and all the residents
out there Battalion Chief Cox thank you
so much thank you